[Música]
hagamos un ejercicio cerremos los ojos e
imaginemos un futuro no muy lejano como
se ven solteros
en mis tiempos se decía de caravana no
sé cómo se dice ahora
casados en parejas que siguen hijos
cuantos algunos debe tener planificada
su vida y debe saber cuantos
mascotas seguro mascotas seguro
fantástico
ahora abramos los ojos y volvamos a la
realidad
qué pasa si no sucede lo que con tanto
esfuerzo tanta imaginación
pensamos el soltero toda la vida de
fiesta
los hijos si en lugar de dos pasan a ser
cuatro o al revés
y si a tu pareja en lugar de los gatos
siameses que son casi de decoración le
gustan los labradores que no entienden
una consigna de por vida
entonces quien puede decir que conoce su
futuro nadie no ok yo les puedo asegurar
que a pesar de este ejercicio hay gente
que cree conocerlo que actúa como si lo
conociera sin saberlo saben quiénes son
la gente que desean construir construir
una casa un quincho una pileta un garage
porque saben perfectamente cuántos autos
quieren tener cuántos hijos van a tener
es más me pasó a asesorar a una persona
que pensaba que nunca iba a envejecer
que iba a tener un cuerpo espléndido
toda la vida esa anécdota se las dejo
para después
ok entonces quién está ahí para ayudar a
esta gente que no sabe
los vengadores
no
los arquitectos
entonces si vamos a hablar de
arquitectura definamos un poquito que es
arquitectura les traigo tres
definiciones de arquitectura de un
montón que encontré ya que dicen que hay
tantas definiciones de arquitectura como
arquitectos la primera es de alejandro
aravena chileno dedicado a la vivienda
social que dice que la arquitectura es
dar forma a los lugares donde vive la
gente no es más complicado que eso pero
tampoco es más sencillo que eso ver qué
jingles que es un arquitecto de nes dice
que la arquitectura es poesía práctica
bárbaro es el primer mundo fantástico
y hay un arquitecto británico norman
foster que dice que la arquitectura es
una expresión de valores la forma en que
vivimos es un reflejo la forma en que
construimos perdón es un reflejo de
nuestra forma de vivir esa es la que más
me gusta obviamente
entonces ahora
todos lo conocen no no necesita
presentación el partenón grecia atenas
los dioses brad pitt bueno
ese creo grade troya
las torres petronas kuala lumpur malasia
obra de un arquitecto argentino un
orgullo que sea argentino el arquitecto
que haya hecho esto
viviendas unifamiliares mi casa la casa
de mi vecina la casa de algunos de
ustedes
ahora bien qué pasa para que nosotros
lleguemos admirar a estas obras al
partenón a las torres petronas que pasó
antes antes pasó una persona que tuvo un
sueño contrato un arquitecto y el
arquitecto interpretó diálogo con esa
persona y construyó lo que éste soñaba
porque un arquitecto no solo se dedica a
construir casas templos edificios un
arquitecto lo que hace es crear un
arquitecto es un co creador único
diseñador de espacios relaciona
interpreta y relaciona a las personas
con la naturaleza con el espacio y con
la sociedad
qué pasó antes cómo llegamos a admirar a
estos edificios antes pasó esto
este plano que curiosamente se parece a
un plano coincide muchísimo dibujado por
mi hija cuando tenía cuatro años y que
hoy estudia arquitectura
alguien es el deseo de alguien alguien
que no tiene las herramientas para
comunicarse en el lenguaje de los
arquitectos pero que sí sabe lo que
quiere hoy entonces analicemos los
por el lugar en donde habita el
salón-comedor y por las dimensiones que
le dan pensemos que le da mucha
importancia a la vida social que es el
lugar en donde pretende pasar la mayor
parte del tiempo
qué sueño tener más mi hijos ya que
diseñan quiere tres dormitorios
que por esas cosas de las fantasías
humanas quiere más intimidad en el
dormitorio principal planteando un baño
en suite como el de las revistas de
decoración esas que son re caras
ok
qué hizo el arquitecto para poder
interpretar este sueño
el arquitecto trabajó con él interpretó
lo que él quería y logró después de
mucho trabajo lo construir el sueño de
esta persona obviamente después de
muchísimas entrevistas de interiorizarse
en la dinámica familiar de presentar
planos en la municipalidad de
interminables discusiones con albañiles
electricistas y gasistas el arquitecto
construyó con esta persona
juntos arquitecto y cliente codo a codo
la casa que soñaron ahora bien también
puede ser para eso hicimos el ejercicio
al principio que no siempre pase lo que
nosotros soñamos
hace algunos años me tocó diseñar una
casa en un barrio privado una pareja una
familia dos hijos muy buen pasar no
escatimó en gastos para construir su
casa soñada
por las dimensiones de la casa según el
programa de necesidades que había
planteado compraron dos lotes a dos a
dos pidieron permisos en el barrio para
agregar detalles que no se podían segura
el reglamento interno y cuando comenzó
así yo teníamos
cerrado el proyecto para empezar a
construirlo se separaron
esto que le sucede a mucha gente
obviamente me dejó pensando en ese
momento y lo traigo hoy porque qué fue
lo que había pasado había pasado que
ellos habían soñado un futuro una idea
de familia pero en el momento de las
entrevistas y del trabajo y yo les había
dibujado la vida que querían en ese
momento
a mí me quedó un dibujo muy bonito de
una casa que iba a ser vivida habitada
disfrutada por una familia que no fue
seguro que también al principio les dije
que tenía una anécdota que les iba a
contar bueno este es el momento también
nos pasó construir una taza para una
pareja que querían dos baños adosados
uno para ella y otro para él y en el
baño de la mujer
eso quería enfrentado a la bañera de
piso a techo y de pared a pared un
espejo
y más allá de que yo estuviera de
acuerdo o no con semejante espejo mi
obligación como profesional era que
grabarlo un golpe de realidad y hacer
que ella se preguntara si de hasta 30
años ella iba a seguir siendo tan amiga
de ese espejo como en este momento en el
momento de la entrevista lo pensó lo
pensó
y cubrimos la pared con unos cerámicos
muy bonitos
bueno aparte de estas anécdotas muchas
veces la mayoría de las veces la casa
funciona y funciona toda la vida y nos
toca adaptarnos muchas veces a nosotros
y a nuestra casa entonces en el salón
comedor que habíamos pensado para las
reuniones sociales a lo mejor se
transforma en la habitación del nono que
no puede vivir más solo
el tiempo pasa y sigue pasando y puede
ser que cuando lleguemos a viejitos nos
encontremos con grandes o pequeñas
construcciones pero nuestra casa que
tuvimos la fortuna de materializar aún
con estos cambios que a lo largo de la
vida se fueron dando
y volvamos a hacer 2
o uno
y sintamos que esa casa nos queda grande
porque física y diariamente esa casa
queda grande pero también puede ser por
como somos los argentinos que esa casa
los fines de semana con amigos los
domingos con la familia se llene de lo
que realmente quisimos construir cuando
empezamos a construir es decir lazos
vínculos
amistad amor
entonces si están soñando con tener su
casa si están pensando en proyectarla si
ya tienen los planos en la mano si están
en esas horas interminables de
discusiones por un piso blanco o negro o
por una ventana grande o chica los
invito a que piensen a que lo que
ustedes se están construyendo es su
futuro pero aquí y ahora y puede que les
lleve meses años décadas terminarlo pero
las vivencias la adrenalina
comienzan el momento en el momento en
que dieron el primer paso
entonces piensen que no son solo
ladrillos son su vida presente y futura
y por lo tanto disfruten y sabor en cada
paso que den para alcanzarla gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]